so we work so we will legislate in the
first year of a Labour government for a
fair deal for those who rent and we're
going to oversee also a revolution in
home ownership in this country they'll
be the biggest house building program
for a generation will build at least
200,000 homes a year by the end of the
Parliament on course to start the
building of 1 million new homes will
unlock five billion pounds for a future
homes fund to help build those new homes
will build a new generation of towns
garden cities and suburbs and we won't
let large developers just hoard land and
we know what happens they wait for it to
go up in value when it could be used to
build homes will say either you use the
land or you lose the land because we
need that building
and as we've laid out new housing will
be our first priority for capital
investment including for council housing
and housing associations but friends we
won't just build homes we'll make sure
there is real priority for first-time
buyers it's simply too expensive for so
many young people to build to buy a home
today saving up for the deposit paying
the fees and having let enough left over
for stamp duty so we're going to act
we're going to put first-time buyers
first for the first three years of the
next Labour government we will abolish
stamp duty for all first-time buyers
buying a home under 300,000 pounds